From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Three, two, one, and rolling.
Today is Saturday, March 9, 2013.
My name is Dr. Hassan Kwame, Jeff Rees of the Ohio State University and the Southern oral history program
at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with videographer, Petna Dalico in Albany, Georgia on the campus of Albany State University
to conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are here this afternoon with Mr. Robert LaClaire.
Mr. McClary, thank you so much for taking the time to talk to us today.
I just want to ask you a couple questions about life growing up.
When were you born?
I was born on October 19th, but I'm a PD Putnam Hospital.
I was born on October 19th, and I was born on October 19th.
I was born on October 19th, and I was born on October 19th, and I was born on October 19th, and I was born on October 19th.
My mother died on that building before I became a teacher.
My father had a job on the river, and he took the family that was left in the house, and we moved to war with it.
George and Northern.
The same thing happened to me.
I was born on October 19th, and I was born on October 19th, and I was born on October 19th, and I was born on October 19th.
It went suddenly to poverty.
I remember one day of my sister, one girl, my sister, my sister, my brother, and my father.
My mother died on October 19th, and she stayed there with my father.
She was about 19 years old at that time.
But definitely, at one day, I called out and learned to walk at about seven years ago.
They were discussing what they were going to do, but all the trouble was over me going to school.
I was going to be around for a day and about myself.
I was going to be around for a day and only going to school.
I loved it.
I was going to be around for a day.
When he Fasted to Gun
keep practicing and he thought that it would be difficult in a way that is difficult to laugh and immersed in.
I mean, I have to tell you, we are always together.
Just today, when one day my father was late, a fairly late my father, or wasn't saying
that we played either.
We were both people getting paid every two weeks.
We played every night before we gave home.
So the misguided was here, and he gave us a chance to learn, start to make up to everything
going into town.
The name was stars and hey, no, no, no, no.
I'm just like man.
And my father was to be stolen to pay the bill.
And then pay the bill, pay the bill, and then pay the bill.
He was stolen to pay the bill.
And this quiet guy, still on the, he won't be able to make up.
He said, surely, I want to hit him for you video.
I want to say, I'm here, I'm here.
He'll turn his leg over.
And he got into the story of my grand-grandson and my brother.
And I told you, come and say, you can't talk to me like that.
I'm alright man.
I want to know, your father was a bit...
You're son for bitch.
That's what your father said.
Before I went over from Carolina to Gigi.
From South Carolina, from South Carolina.
You wanted him to be the person.
But he...
I love it, I'm fine because he has a confrontation with a white man.
He was blown down and he was talking about this.
Wow.
Anyway, I went to school and went to school.
The wall we had last two two school, I had the stories printed on it.
Like the football ball, white football.
I had to go across the field, around the field with the club.
I went to the field of the church.
I saw the French and English grades.
I think I'm asking for grades because I was an old one of the stars.
And I went to school.
I was a French school kid.
And I went to...
I went...
To...
To the hospital.
For high school kids, just built a school.
Okay.
For one family.
For black folks.
They were...
You know, one of the stuff was...
The vehicles.
It was like graduate.
They thought they had an integrated inner way.
So, there's a lake in these different families to start the integration process.
One of those was good ones.
The young people, the daughter, the young.
And...
She had a competition with the white guy on the bus.
And white salad on the bus.
The vehicle.
But...
Yeah.
They took the...
So, development, you know.
And the internal model is yours.
And the...
Let's start the movement in moving.
But before that time, I already...
Got involved in the movement.
Shortly after.
Shortly after...
Six to four.
When the boarding right at the side.
I always think you're in a position.
And I thought these two people coming down to me.
Oh.
All right, girl.
It looked like you.
And the young white boy.
And they were talking.
He was laughing.
And they had a club board.
He feels good.
And I'm like, what do you mean?
You know that?
So, they work.
And they work here on people in the county.
People in the street.
The campus in the old campus in the county.
Yeah.
I thought they took down my dress.
And they took down the hair.
They...
They had...
An awful lot of changes.
It was a young white guy.
A black girl in the old campus in the county.
Okay.
They had a new people.
You know what?
It was a young boy.
They had a new people called the Albany.
Because of the side.
Yeah, on the side.
And when the attention got more...
Hey, Jeff.
You know, I'm working in the building.
You know, this is the...
So...
I would have had a couple of new people in the building.
But you know...
Well...
You know, I guess for you.
I would have been using the door and movement.
Wow.
So you wrote for the paper.
Sent it in.
Yeah.
And then Shiraah was like,
I was feeling without that.
I always think of the table.
That means my brother or you should meet him at night.
You can help him with your hands.
Now, would these be mass meetings and words?
Or would they be down in Albany or...
It was kind of...
It was.
It turned out that...
My brother tried to organize about nine calories in South America.
It was a pity being there.
And we were going to take over one of the calories.
Electrically.
You know, there's...
That was...
That was planned.
Shiraah was an activist anyway.
But I went to a meeting in...
Dr. Yomha, but you know,
at first, I didn't...
Yeah.
I mean the money in different characters.
And that's when I joined the party.
And Shiraah gave me...
Okay, look.
And for you to kill me.
Yeah.
We have all of this.
And Jeff was to kill me.
And Jeff was to treat me.
Oh, Jeff was to treat me.
One, two, three, and now...
Sure.
Mr. McLary, apologize for the 15 or so minute delay that we had to change some stuff out, technically.
When we stopped, you were talking about...
You were working with Shiraah.
You had joined the...
Joy's movement.
Yeah.
What's...
What were some of the activities that you did in the movement?
Well, we...
We are...
Tennis...
And people are getting the bone.
Tennis is getting the bone.
We get the welfare activities.
People...
They're not getting welfare.
They were giving me any welfare.
And we had...
And we did it.
Every time they took them down, we used...
A peel that...
And...
Yeah.
Why people...
When used to...
Like becoming...
Appearing through you.
And that would anytime for now.
Most...
Most of the people there had gone to the...
Right on the church...
And...
That's like...
Most of the white folks.
Yeah.
All of the white folks here had gone.
And they were sitting in the house to themselves.
That's like...
Well, we...
Not a young woman...
Would come get me on a daily basis when I was being home.
And we got...
And took the people...
A lot...
Resisting to go.
A lot of their welfare.
Problems.
And about school really goes...
Like that.
Also, a...
A...
I have the record, not all of the support things.
The only...
Buffet.
Got...
Got a job...
As a
Get to work in a moment.
Cartag radical...
Can I...?
Oh.
I leave it with a walk.
Ra....
And from somehow to day nine...
And just to go back a little bit to you also engage in some attempts to desegregate some places.
There was a cafe down in the hometown. I want to go see them.
What was it called? A casino. A casino.
And you can go into your back, go to the back window.
And what about them? Did you ask them just to help?
But you know, when what activists came down to wake us from New York was over here.
She went to a portal to come down. I didn't get the name of a white guy.
But he was trying to make light to spin the back with me.
I thought she was around and he was saying, yeah, I can't.
We went down to the casino.
And I didn't get to go into the back window. And just, I just said, well, I didn't like my wasn't.
I mean, I couldn't do it.
You think you're going in front door?
I mean, if I don't just slide down there and he said, they got to pull me.
And I was like, you know, this is smart. I didn't know anybody.
They think I was going to get this hair.
So it was made by a veteran to get a one-on-one that could go for years.
But he didn't let the guy, I think he said, we closed.
I didn't really know anyone. He closed the place and they were opening the game.
I stopped there because I didn't mean to talk to them.
I just vaguely thought.
Right, making a point.
Can you say Sharad didn't know about that?
I need to be told a little about you.
Boy, that little thing I was having a time I got attacked.
I was sleeping in office.
On Mother's Beach, three or seven thousand Mother's Beach.
And I had a room with the other room at the office.
And then they were big friends.
They were big friends.
And other day I had not gotten by him the door.
And then into the door.
Living room and that's all for you right from there.
Going in the hands.
I had no chance to write a thing with you.
But I left that door.
I didn't know.
I don't think I can.
You see you.
And they have all my knowledge.
You thought about it.
You thought about pulling this thing in that special?
You know, I don't know how to do that.
I can just like open like this.
They know this right.
And I want to tell you the little of the living room.
Which I want.
They called me with a man.
I don't know me.
For the guy.
Oh, look at me.
I'm trying to be with the people.
And the payment break.
The thing I knew I was on the floor.
On the other side of the building.
They were checking me.
I got a room.
I finally convinced him that I didn't know where this guy was.
And there I was over there.
The police living there.
I was going to school with over the street.
One of the other staff members came up.
And I didn't know if he was trying to kill him.
They left behind him.
And he took over.
They took away.
The police got him the same night.
In the night.
And the police got him the same night.
And then they went to the police station.
They told me that I was going to school.
And then they told me that I was going to school.
The police got him the same night.
I was going to school.
I'm going to school.
What did you do?
I don't know.
I was going to school.
But I just wanted to go back home.
You can't even write. You don't have anything to teach you that either. You don't have to go so much.
So instead of just going to show you a video of the YouTube, who are the people that we say on this YouTube.
We are learning to type and now that you're science, we got to quickly forgot it.
Here's how to do it.
If I came back here, somebody told me how to do it. You don't just laugh it.
Do the long move. It's just like that. That's what I need.
I don't do it. That's what I'm telling you. The delay made it for you to do it.
Oh, for Southwest Jordan. It's for the project.
Is there anything else that you would like to add for us to get on tape?
Well, let I can think about the type of my age.
It's self-defense, like I said before. You don't move it. You can't retire.
Because it's become a party mode.
The next time I was making 20 people the party, dragging all the ladies into the board board.
The white people there were. Look at that. That was a dream.
Mr. Oden, you going in there? Come on. Come on.
For the middle of the board, made a board.
What town was this?
Right after the school board, I was making a board.
Was this in Norway? Yes. This was in Norway.
It was in Norway.
I don't know why this. I didn't do that.
But I didn't do that. I didn't do that.
I didn't do that.
For doing that? Yes.
But I didn't know why.
I didn't do that.
Trying to make me stop.
But so much went on doing that long thing.
I didn't know why.
We have to help.
We have to help people with different challenges on Monday morning,
people with a lot of morning.
We go up to the next challenge and do what we need to accomplish.
We have people in the world.
But in that little town like that, we got the first black male of one with, which was, well,
it was the left during the last three because he died.
But we did get a black male and one with, I wasn't there, but it's all gone with the
results too then.
Yes, yes.
What last question?
Were you ever afraid?
I was more hopeful than I was.
I was hopeful and excited than I was afraid.
I remember when I say my father, he always complained about other people being told to be
intimate.
And he would not take it out of the way, get it, revive, but like I tell you, he's the only man
who's been told to be a black male.
I don't have physical conversation with a black guy and live the town for black.
I said, he's the only man he gives me black male.
I said, man, that's not anything.
I said, that's a good thing.
I don't know.
Geeky hair.
They weren't backing down.
If you thought, or bad news, you should have just run against him.
He won't back up.
He's poor.
I don't know what I heard.
He's dead.
He's a new guy.
Wow.
Well, Mr. McClary, thank you so much for sharing your thoughts and experiences.
It has been a real honor to talk to you.
I'm a little bit, you know, I be comfortable, but I don't have any notes in me.
I'm sure of this, I'm pretty.
That's all right.
Anything with me, we'll get it again.
All right.
Thank you.
Wonderful.
All right.
Yeah.
One.
From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History
and Culture.